Today
We're making
The World's
Spinniest
Ping pong table
And for that
We need 150
table tennis rubbers
Which we're gonna spread
Onto the surface
At the end of this video
Stay tuned
We're gonna try the world's most
Impossible serve
Edge bounce
To edge bounce
Let's see how many tries it takes
after this we know
What's the likelyhood of
Making this shot in a tournament
Ready for this serve Emil?
Oh that was like
Nooo
Ten centimeters
300 tries
Maybe?
So close
Maybe in the top 5
Hardest things we’ve done
Emil, chocolate break
Let's try
Speaking of chocolate
We're going to make the world's largest
Table tennis racket
Made completely out of chocolate
If we reach 5 Million subscribers
By the end of the year
Make sure to subscribe so we can make this happen
There we have it
So that took us one and a half hours
About 1000 attempts
Not the easiest serve
Choose your color
I'll take the pink one
Can you get spin with it
Yes you can
Actually that was!
No idea
Where the ball is gonna go
Emil should be
Afraid of jackpots
Oh we got it!
I have a good idea...
It didn't work
But it was a good idea!
Next challenge is
Diagonal table
That's quite good
It actually works
Probably my best roller ever
I'm on the wrong side
of the table
And there i miss it!
I was already sure that I
Lost the point
Came on my side!
Yeah this was a fun set-up
We're still missing
Rubber table
So make sure you watch until the end
Like this
Come and play against...
Me, Emil
Against you?
Yeah
Bit itchy...
Forehand
FOREHAND
Ghost serve!?
Can't reach
There
nononononono
SMASH!
Yes!
Another one backhand!
Take a quick...
Water brake
Sure, sure
yeah...
Good to stay hydrated
Forehand
And...
backhandbackhandbackhand
We won we won we won!
I think we did a good job
So we invented a new shot...
The behind the back snake
One hunder and forty four rubbers
To cover a table tennis table
The spin is going to be crazy
Watch out i'm giving you a sidespin
It's easy to give around the net spots with this
It's gonna be fast
That's the new world's fastest serve
Nice game!
I think we should
Fill the whole table
Emils side
Oh yeah!
Alex check out our table
That's a lot of rubbers
Don't forget to subscribe guys
The moment we have all been waiting for
We are gonna play on the world's
Spinniest
Table tennis table
That's a good one
That was good
That's why it's called the world's spinniest table
We're going to finds someone
To challenge us on this table
So we have Jokke here
Hi everybody
Jokke are you ready to
try out the new table?
Of course
Zero-zero
Jokke actually has the blue rubber
Only one loss with the blue rubber
Maybe this is the second loss
He got it
I'm 60 but i'm still quite fast!
Nice return
Watch out boy!
Jokke is destroying me
Good match
Let's try a chop
I'm gonna like the chopping
I was close
That's the right one
I need to continue from that
I knew there was nothing i could do
When we reach
5 MIllion subscribers
It will be the world's biggest chocolate
Ping pong racket
Make sure to subscribe